ce continuent de circuler au brésil les
cas de contamination sont en hausse plus
de 220 mille cas pour presque quinze
mille décès liés au corps 19 avec en
prime un deuxième ministre la santé qui
démissionne en un mois puis marc aussi
décidément en temps de pandémie
la carrière d'une femme ou d'un homme
politique peut être mise à rude épreuve
ce vendredi le ministre brésilien de la
santé nelson tech a rendu son
portefeuille
un mois seulement après sa prise de
fonction une démission justifiée par des
divergences de vue sur les mesures de
lutte contre le coronavirus comme l'a
indiqué son désormais ex ministère
nelson tech qui le jour de sa nomination
tentait pourtant un numéro
d'équilibriste entre des mesures
sanitaires inévitable et la volonté de
jaillir ball sonar ou de préserver
l'économie du pays à tout prix c'était
un débat entre la santé et l'économie
c'est très mauvais parce que ces choses
ne sont pas en concurrence les unes avec
les autres
elles sont complètement complémentaires
quand vous polarisé quelque chose comme
ça vous commencez à le traiter comme
s'il s'agissait des gens contre l'argent
pour ses personnages vers sujet pourtant
nelson taille j'avais été choisi
personnellement par jaillir boyz and are
où il y a un mois pour succéder au
populaire luiz henrique mone d'état en
désaccord avec le chef de l'état
brésilien sur les mesures à adopter face
à l'épidémie
contrairement au président brésilien
mende d'état était opposé à la
chloroquine est partisan d'un
confinement élargie ce qui lui avait
valu un limogeage en bonne et due forme
depuis le début de l'épidémie
le président brésilien a minimisé
systématiquement l'ampleur de la crise
comme le 24 mars dernier où il avait
évoqué l'hystérie des médias face à ce
qu'il appelait une petite grippe avant
de parler deux semaines plus tard de
l'importance de préserver l'emploi
alors que la moitié de l'humanité était
confiné le climato sceptiques et
désormais corona sceptiques président
brésilien s'oppose de plus en plus aux
mesures de confinement prise par le
gouverneur et autres élus locaux du pays
le brésil s'effondre et apre s est
effondré l'économie ne se relèvera pas
comme certains disent elle ne se
relèvera pas nous allons avoir
et de misère comme les pays d'afrique
subsaharienne des gens meurent ben oui
désolé je suis désolé mais il y aura
plus de gens qui mourront beaucoup plus
si l'économie continue d'être détruite
par ces mesures
l'appel que je lance aux gouverneurs est
le suivant repenser cette politique je
suis prêt à en discuter
pourtant la pandémie de covile 19 est en
train de frapper violemment le brésil
que l'on pensait relativement épargnée
dernièrement la courbe du nombre de cas
s'est emballé tout comme celle des décès
qui ont plus que doublé en deux semaines
le brésil semble donc à la croisée des
chemins a mesuré les risques d'une
hécatombe ou ceux d'un effondrement
économique